KEITH: Jerry Stahl,
he's the author
of the memoir "Permanent
Midnight," which
was made into a movie
starring Ben Stiller,
and "Perv-- A Love
Story," both of which
were "Los Angeles Times"
best sellers, as well
as acclaimed novels
"Painkillers,"
"Plainclothes naked."
He's also written extensively
for film and television.
He recently wrote the
screenplay for the HBO
film "Hemingway and
Gellhorn," which
starred Clive Owen
and Nicole Kidman,
and his much anthologized
fiction and journalism
have appeared in "Esquire,"
"Details," "Playboy,"
"BlackBook," "LA
Weekly," and "Tin House."
He is a resident of
Los Angeles, which
makes us extra special
happy to have him here.
So let me go ahead
and hand it over.
Everybody, this is Jerry Stahl.
JERRY STAHL: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JERRY STAHL: Thanks
so much for letting
me take over your lunch hour.
It's really exciting
to be here for me.
You know, I was
just using a urinal,
over which I noticed a little
sticker for blaze dependency
testing.
At which point, I
got paranoid there
was a drug I was addicted to
that I've never even heard of,
and they were going
to test my urine.
But if anyone can
relate to that joke,
they're probably not here now.
That's what I'm guessing.
But I was just telling
Keith before, it's
really convenient-- I don't
want to-- I love Google
as if they were blood
relatives of mine.
But I was mentioning when
you go to my Google page--
and I have to say that
with my wife here--
but it mentions that I'm married
to Brandy Alexandre, who nobody
will admit knowing was a porn
star in the '80s who I've never
personally met, never
even seen any of her work.
And I was just consulting--
it was very fortuitous for me
to be here at Google, so
I could figure out a way
to tell the world,
when they Google me
and see me in the
corner, that I'm not
in fact married to Brandy.
We were never friends.
It was never serious.
I never met her.
And it means nothing to you.
I'm dying up here.
But on to "Happy
Mutant Baby Pills,"
which is my newest book.
I'm going to try to be
as close as possible,
so there will be
feedback to the mic.
Wow, the electricity
in this room.
Sometimes-- I've spoken
all over the world,
and sometimes you
just go to a place,
and you just feel
that vibe, like wow.
This is an audience
that's on fire.
I can't lie.
I don't know what they're
putting in those mung beans.
So as my host, Keith,
mentioned-- what he left off
the resume is that I was
a professional heroin
user for a number of years,
which was really a great career
move for me because it got me
a book deal and a movie deal.
And I was doing a
lot of research,
which I didn't know was
research at the time.
And I mention that because
all my books are essentially
part of one big, massively
OK-selling oeuvre.
And this book, "Happy
Mutant Baby Pills,"
which I see they have on
the chair, which makes me
feel like I'm in geography
class, which is kind of great.
The textbook is there.
This book relates to drugs
because the story behind it,
even though it's a novel, is--
like all junkies of the '80s
and '90s, including the
late, lamented Lou Reed,
I got hepatitis C,
which is what you
get if you're lucky
enough not to get AIDS.
Not to get technical, but if
you bleached your needles,
you would kill the hep C.
But you needed to boil them
for 10 minutes to
not-- I mean, you
wouldn't get AIDS if
you used to bleach.
As you can see, drugs
have affected my memory.
So if I'm not exactly
linear, indulge me.
Or not.
And to kill the
AIDS virus, you had
to boil needles for 10 minutes.
And junkies are always in a
hurry, because places to go
and people to see.
I didn't do that.
So what happened is two things.
Right before I started
writing this book,
Abbott Pharmaceuticals came
up with a cure for the disease
I had, or so they thought.
And I did a trial drug
program at Cedars-Sinai.
Pays me massively to
plug them wherever I go.
I am, by the way,
contractually bound
to mention heroin and
Cedars-Sinai whenever I speak.
So that's out of the way.
We can get back to business.
And long story short, the
second I took the first pill,
and they started talking to
me, they said, oh by the way,
this stuff is so toxic
that if you so much as
touch a pregnant woman,
or if you happen to sweat
and she touches a little drop
of your sweat in your bed,
your baby will essentially
be born purple with wheels.
That's not what they said.
I'm being scientific.
We've already lost one.
And Lenny Bruce said, if
people don't start walking out
in the first five minutes,
you're fucking up.
So I'm glad they're fleeing.
If there's not an empty
room by the time we're done,
I will have failed.
And what happened is, my
girlfriend, now my wife,
had just told me that
she was pregnant.
So boy was my face red.
So I've just gotten married.
We're pregnant.
And I'm now on a drug that
is so toxic, if I sneeze
in her direction, we're
going to have a sideshow
act on our hands when the kid's
born, if we're optimistic.
So had to get rid
of her for a while.
We split up while she was
pregnant-- which is just
a lovely thing to do
to a pregnant woman--
so that I could be on
this massively toxic drug,
the other side effect of which
was-- I'm sure none of you
have had this experience-- was
basically aside from itching,
sweating, all that, all
the normal stuff, which
I'm no stranger
to, was basically
like being on bad acid, not
to brag, for about 12 weeks.
Which is great for a
writer, but not so great
for getting through life.
So it occurred to me
a couple of things.
I was a drug addict
for years and put
God knows what strain of
bus station toilet water
into my veins.
And now I'm on these drugs that
are totally legitimate, more
or less, because they
haven't been FDA approved,
and they're so toxic, and
there's so many of them,
that I became obsessed
with all the drugs
we are taking that are
kind of involuntary.
And I became obsessed with
the impact on pregnant women.
probably really the creepiest
side effect of the fact that
there is complete deregulation
and that there is
GMOs in everything
and that there is pesticides and
that Monsanto runs the world,
and if you have stock
in them, forgive me.
It will go up, and we will
die, but what the hell.
The point is, even
mother's milk at this point
has Benzene, toilet cleaner,
window washer, lithium,
which in my case, my kid
gets a little free lithium,
it wouldn't be the worst
thing in the world.
And it freaked me out.
So I wrote a book about
this because what can you
do when you're a novelist?
You have all this information,
and you have a captive audience
if someone decides
to pick up your book.
And you've got to
make it entertaining.
So that was the
impetus for this book.
Because as I walked
in, so many of you
took me aside and
said, Jerry, what
was the impetus
for this book you
wrote that I've never heard of?
And I wanted to
answer that question
so that you wouldn't
walk away unsatisfied.
How's lunch, by the way?
Is it good?
Everybody good?
I'm trying not to say fucking
too much because as I was also
telling Keith as I walked
in, the last time I actually
had an office job-- and again,
I don't mean to brag-- after I
got off heroin, I was working
at McDonald's at the age of 38.
A man in uniform, ladies.
Poly blend.
In Phoenix, I'd say
it's about 105 degrees.
And my job, among others,
speaking of poisons,
was to-- every morning,
they would deliver the meat
into the parking lot and leave
the patties outside in like 105
degrees, vaguely green.
And I got to like scoop
the patties up, take them
inside, let them thaw a little.
And then I got to make the Egg
McMuffin, Egg McMuffin batter.
And because you
are eating lunch,
I won't elaborate
on the fact that I
got fired for being caught
urinating into the Egg McMuffin
batter.
But not the first time.
So consider the next time
you have a McDonald's, all
that-- I see that guy
putting his lunch aside.
And forgive me.
I rarely speak at meal times.
We would have provided
buckets, had I known.
Consider the number of
disgruntled employees
who are in the back.
Because now, your average
McDonald's employee is like
a guy with an engineering degree
who couldn't get into Google
so now he's at
fucking McDonald's.
So it is kind of your
fault, but not really.
I didn't want to go there.
But yeah, I mean,
essentially, you're
putting a man in a McDonald's
uniform just by being here.
But I made it out, happily.
I'd probably still be at
McDonald's, had they not fired
me.
They had a-- I'm just going to
ramble a little bit because it
is Hollywood.
They had a movie we had to watch
on how to make the fries when I
got to McDonald's.
And it had a really kind
of a great looking guy
and a great looking--
I'm going to say gal.
I don't usually use the
word gal, but she was a gal.
And I remember thinking, boy, I
bet they went to acting school.
This is probably some
Juilliard graduate,
and the best they could do is
get a gig doing the how to make
fry tape for McDonald's.
And I guess none of you
guys have had bad jobs.
I'm an expert at bad jobs.
Which brings us back to
"Happy Mutant Baby Pills."
I don't know why
I'm holding it up.
I feel like I'm in a
fucking infomercial.
I had the experience, in my
life, with a lot of bad jobs.
And one of the
characters in this book
is a guy whose gig is writing
the side effects on pills.
I'm sure you've all
seen them late at night,
when you see the ads.
So he's the guy.
His claim to fame is that he
came up with the phrase anal
leakage, which is not as easy
as it thinks because you don't
want to say seepage, which
is what it really was.
The side effects
of a lot of drugs,
including olestra, which was in
a lot of those low cal potato
chips, it'll be suicidal
thoughts, sweating,
night sweats,
frequent urination.
Enjoy your lunch.
But you never realize
what's in your fucking head
until you get plunged in front
of a room full of 40 people.
And as you can see, I've
prepared extensively
for this talk because I
tour the world speaking
about this as an
inspirational speaker.
Me and Tony Danza, essentially.
We're like this.
And so this guy's job was
to write these things,
and he was a failed writer.
But he came up with anal
leakage, and he got promoted.
So I became obsessed with
the side effects and the fact
that restless knee syndrome,
for example, didn't exist.
They actually hire
people to invent diseases
so that they can peddle
cures so that guys
like him, in this
book, this guy Lloyd,
can be hired to write the
side effects for a pill
for a disease that was
only created to cure
the disease they invented
to sell the pill.
Sort of how Monsanto
has developed
a pesticide-resistant
plant, that is now
in all the GMOs, that resists
Roundup, which was developed
by Monsanto, so that they could
sell another pesticide that
will work.
It's just great.
Because basically, we're all
eating pesticides all the time,
and they're all inside us.
And now every baby's
born with asthma.
Now, as you can tell, I
have a scientific mind,
and I'm laser sharp,
and I'm sure you all
understand that this is a book
about a guy whose first job was
writing bad side
effects to medications
and making them sound festive.
Making it OK.
Because seepage, to get back
to my original point, seepage,
ladies and gentleman, is nasty.
I mean, around the
house, in your body,
nothing that seeps can be good.
But leakage, that is a kind
of around the house thing.
Tires leak.
Faucets leak.
So he had the touch.
And I have had jobs like this.
He also wrote the side
effects for other medications.
He also wrote the
descriptions for marital aids,
which sex toys
used to be called.
Sidebar, not to make
myself look good,
but before I worked
at McDonald's, I
got a job-- because
I do have a college
degree-- I got a job being
humor editor at "Hustler."
And I was really
young, and I thought
it would be really exciting.
And I went to Columbus, Ohio,
and they're giving me the tour,
and I thought, wow,
this is going to be hot.
And they take me down a hall,
and they open this door,
and there's about--
do any of you
remember "The Andy
Griffith Show?"
Anybody?
No?
Yeah.
Aunt Bee?
There was a room full
of ladies with beehives
who looked like the kindergarten
teacher you had in 1968,
'75, '52, stuffing
dildos into boxes.
And they were just like church
ladies, room full of them,
stuffing sex toys into boxes.
Why do I mention it here?
No reason.
But it came into my head,
and it seemed very relevant
to this book.
Because this is a book
about a guy with bad jobs.
His job after this was writing
the festive descriptions
for Christian Singles,
which was a website, which
I hope some of you have enjoyed.
I don't know if any of you
are like JDaters or OK Cupid.
This guy had the job of writing
copy for Christian Singles--
Christian Swingles in the book--
and he didn't like his job.
He ends up getting fired.
He meets a woman,
in a roundabout way,
he meets a woman whose job
she has decided in life,
she feels fucked
over by big pharma.
She feels like she's
been screwed over.
She wants to have
the most mutant baby
she can have as a protest
against capitalism.
So she is on a mission
to consume every over
the counter-- see ya-- under
the counter, beside the counter,
from huffing paint, to all the
good stuff we do every day.
For example, forget drugs.
If you're pregnant
and need tomato soup,
the lining of the can
will deform your baby.
Good news.
But nobody tells you that.
So she decides to consume
everything she can,
every drug, every kind of like
food stuff that is semi nasty,
like meat, chicken, poultry.
Watch the movie "Food, Inc."
It's a great movie.
It shows you how
chickens are treated
and how cows are treated.
God, I sound like
some wild-eyed radical
up here when the fact is,
I would kill for a Big Mac
right now if I didn't
know what was in it.
So these two people--
it's a love story.
It's a guy who had this
job-- and they're both heroin
addicts, because I
did some research,
and I knew a little about that.
And it's really
kind of a metaphor
for the world we live in, which
is one of involuntary drug
consumption.
And as I say, it's
an interesting read
for some people because
while I wrote this book,
I basically couldn't put a
sentence together in my head
and was on this
medication, which
was so strange because the
FDA hadn't approved it.
And in fact, I think-- I'm not
sure if the version I was on
is the one that was approved,
but it's a very strange thing
to know you're being cured.
I mean, it's crazy.
I was one of those guys,
I did every-- because
I'd basically been told
I was dying for 20 years.
And I wouldn't do the
main thing they wanted
me to do, which was
interferon, because it
was a very hard, hard treatment,
and people would often
commit suicide on it or-- it
was worse than the disease.
So I finally get cured.
I'm the guy who rails
against big pharma.
I get my shit nuked in a week.
I'm like, the virus
is gone, but I
have to continue
taking questionably
odd brain-twisting
bad acid for 12 weeks.
And so I write
this book, where I
can utilize all this
information that I'm
learning, what it does to
pregnant women, what happens
to us just by existing
in this world,
the fact that we live
in America, where
we get to breathe and eat and
sleep and consume everything.
I mean, you guys
work with computers,
so I'm sure you know that
all the completely rare earth
minerals that go
into like the tiniest
little part of the
iPhone or a Prius
are mined by like these
poor bastards in Africa who
are going to be
completely mutant
and radiated themselves
just from digging it up.
And China owns 90% of them
because they own the places
in Africa where the mines are.
So it's all good news.
And it's all stuff I
tried to put in this book.
And as you can tell, it's
kind of a light hearted romp.
Because when you're dealing
with this kind of information,
you don't want to hit people
over the head with it.
You don't want to repel
them, the way I apparently
am by driving lunch eaters
out into the hall retching.
But you want to get
the information out.
And I've been very lucky because
I get to do this for a living
now.
The thing about writing
is, you're basically
paid to be a weirdo.
I was a terrible,
terrible student.
I was a terrible
guitar player, which
I wanted to be a
rock and roll guy.
So when I was a kid, unlike
you, who were probably in school
and doing all these smart
things, I'm thinking to myself,
I want a job.
I can do alone, naked,
and fucked up at 4:00
in the morning, and
maybe make a dime.
It's a high bar,
but I went for it.
And now that those
things no longer matter,
I kind of have that job.
But at my age, I don't
parade around naked at 4:00
in the morning
because complaints,
family, social services.
I can't do it.
I just can't do it.
Wow, this is a tough room.
I'm used to speaking
to people at night
who are drunk, so forgive me.
You may need a drink.
So the thing I did
before this, by the way,
was a movie for HBO about
Hemingway and Gellhorn.
If you ever heard
of Martha Gellhorn,
I'm just going to
ramble here because she
was a much braver-- I'm going to
switch and talk about World War
II.
Martha Gellhorn was a journalist
who was the only person
to be at the
invasion of Normandy
while Hemingway was
off drinking in a bar
somewhere with his buddies.
She disguised herself as
a nurse and got there.
Why do I mention her?
Because in this movie-- and I
got a lot of flack for this--
I'm switching out of
chemicals because I just
decided lunchtime is no time
to discuss toxic chemicals.
Little late in the game.
I don't know how much
time we still have.
But it just occurred to
me, if I were having lunch,
I wouldn't want to
listen to a guy babbling
about anal leakage.
I mean, who would?
Bad choice of
material on my part.
So we're going to switch and
talk about culture now, HBO.
We all love HBO.
I do.
They employed me.
I got to-- we all
have dreams, right?
I wrote this movie
about Martha Gellhorn,
and I got to hear
my lines come out
of Nicole Kidman's mouth,
which is pretty exciting.
And I got to talk about a woman
who really meant a lot to me
because she was so much
braver than Hemingway.
And there's actually
a journalism award
in her name in England every
year for the journalist
who takes the most
physical risks
in the pursuit of a story.
And why do I mention that?
Because if you are a writer,
and if you're wired like me,
you can turn any
triumph into an occasion
for peculiar and petty shame.
That's how writers operate.
They get more-- it's sort
of like a really lame mass
metaphor of the
oyster and the sand.
They can turn all
triumph into shame.
So in my case, I got to go
to "con," "can," you decide.
"Cans"?
C-A-N-N-E-S. Experts?
Linguists?
Keith is a linguist.
He probably knows
how to pronounce it.
KEITH: "Con."
JERRY STAHL: Cannes?
Easy for you to say.
Yeah, OK.
So I was at "can."
And I'm on the red carpet
for no apparent reason.
It's dream come true.
Here-- I'm dropping
names, by the way.
Clive Owen.
And it was great
because the shame
that I managed to attain
here-- and I mention this
because it's going to be
material for a next massively
mediocre selling book
that I have in mind.
I'm on the red carpet.
It's me, Nicole
Kidman, Clive Owen.
We're all like this.
I have my picture taken.
I, of course, popped
a button in my shirt,
so there's like a little
shame bush of chest hair
just like popping out.
All over the world, my
moment in the sun, and I've
got like the bush of death, the
very untrendy '70s chest hair--
ladies-- puffing
out of my shirt.
And that will be the basis
of my entire new novel.
And I just wanted to mention
the fact that even though,
OK, you're here listening to a
guy babbling about anal leakage
and how everything
you eat will kill you
and babies will be born mutant
and America is in trouble,
but you know what, he had
his moment in the sun,
and it was eclipsed by
a thatch of chest hair.
And I think we can
all learn from that.
Another thing I didn't
do when I came up here
was tell you about a
book I wrote before this.
This is "Happy
Mutant Baby Pills."
Most of my stuff is very
high brow, as you can tell.
I wrote a book before
this, where I really-- it
was mostly for academics.
It was called "Bad
Sex on Speed."
Yeah.
Where, like this, I
talked about-- they're
sort of sister
and brother books,
so I'm not sure which
gender is which.
And now there are
50 new genders,
so I really don't
have to decide.
Gender fluid, I think
is what my books are.
And also discussing
the plague of drugs.
But in this case,
methedrine, which
is really big, as some of
you kids may have-- you
may know somebody with no teeth.
I have a friend who is
a paramedic in Missouri,
who told me the most common burn
now is when meth cookers are
in their labs and get careless.
We've all seen "Breaking Bad."
They don't just
blow off their face.
They blow off the entire
front of their body.
So in effect, they
become Ken dolls,
if you know what I'm saying.
And it's very hard to repair.
But in prison, it's
a badge of honor
to be a cook with no
genitals and no face.
Don't ask me why.
I'm not in prison.
I wanted to mention that.
Why?
Because you're having lunch.
Because you're having
lunch, and I think
you need to know that there
are novelists out there
on the front lines of
really good news for us
in the millennial years.
I mean, I have a baby
who's 20 months old,
and I have a daughter
who is 24 years old.
Every 23 years, I pop
out another little girl.
Because really, you want
a child when you're 59.
I mean, it only makes sense
that I should be sitting here
sweating whether she'll be out
of diapers before I'm in them.
Sidebar.
You should know a little
bit about the writers
who are talking here.
I know you've had
a lot of notables.
And I wanted you to know
this is the guy standing
before you now.
Because I know when I worked
at McDonald's-- and again,
there I go dropping names--
we didn't get lunch breaks
so much.
We had inspirational
speakers once in a while.
And one of the reasons
I'm so happy to be here is
because the last inspirational
speech I heard was
at McDonald's.
And they said, you should
smile bright enough
to make your customer
need sunglasses.
I don't know about you,
but it still gets me.
I have that on a
pamphlet from McDonald's.
Because, you know,
we all have bad days.
And on my bad days, I
just look above my desk
at the McDonald's
pamphlet, which
has a whole section on
NJJ, new job jitters,
where it talks about how
often we should shower,
how to shower, why to shower,
and how to smile so brightly.
Which was a little scary
for me, because when
I was working at McDonald's,
again, at 38, fresh off heroin,
my teeth weren't even yellow.
They were working
their way up to yellow.
There were a vaguely greenish
furry around the edges color.
Enjoy your lunch.
And I couldn't get
that smile to happen.
And I got fired.
And I guess I've mentioned it
twice, so it must still hurt.
So ladies and gentleman, the
point is we live in a time
where to breathe is
to kill ourselves.
We live in a time where
essentially everything
we know or think
we know is wrong.
My book before this and
before the book before this,
"Painkillers," was about
the fact that the Nazis won.
Why do I say that?
Because thanks to
these chemicals,
we are essentially, through
no means of our own,
committing mass genocide on
our own people via cancer.
I'm sure you just saw
that report that came out
that said in 10 to 15 years,
the cancer rate is going
to keep doubling, to by the time
my lovely little daughter is
in her 20s, 70% to 80%
of the American public
is going to have cancer.
Why?
So that some fuck who
works for big pharma
can have a second
home and a yacht.
Now, I say that with
love, by the way.
And I know they will
have to bleep me.
I apparently was
the first person
from my last Google
lecture-- and I'm
thrilled they asked me
back, a little surprised.
I was the first
person who ever had
to be bleeped at
a Google lecture.
Because you just
can't hide class,
I guess is what I'm saying.
And interestingly
enough, first vegetarian?
First celebrity
vegetarian, anybody?
Adolph Hitler.
Thank you.
Yeah.
He ate veggies.
Wouldn't undress in
front of anybody else,
and had one testicle.
Thanks for asking.
Blown off in World War I,
which may explain World War II,
some theorize.
Now you say to
yourself, this guy
is just fucking Nazis
up here babbling.
He has no logical structure.
It's all part of a plan.
You know what that plan is?
To make you kids feel good.
To make you feel that
there is some hope.
And there is.
There is some hope.
We're all going
to die eventually.
We'll be out of it.
That's the hope.
The other hope is-- excuse me.
My wife will leave
me after this speech.
But you know, it's OK, because
Brandy Alexander, according
to Google, is waiting for me.
And boy, was she hot in 1982.
Oh, my, god.
I believe she starred
in "Bad Penny."
She always turns up.
That was her banner vehicle.
By the way, again, not to brag,
when I was a kid in my 20s,
and I first got to
Hollywood, I wrote a movie
about the effects
of nuclear war.
It was around the time of "Mad
Max" and "Liquid Sky" and all
these movies, which were
about the apocalypse.
But we were very
young and naive.
And we took money from some
investors who operated out
of a place on Hollywood
Boulevard that
used to be called The
Cave, which turned out
to be a porn theater.
But it literally had
stalactites and stalagmites.
So it was a realistic cave.
It was almost like a
diorama in a museum.
And I knew the first
sign we were in trouble
was when we go to get
our first payment, we
had to walk through the
theater, 2:00 in the afternoon,
with guys in their rain
coats hunched in back.
We had to cross in
front of the screen
while they were showing possibly
my ex-wife, who I've never met,
Brandy Alexandre, who's
really-- apparently
I'm still married to.
But you can't believe everything
you see on the internet.
And I went upstairs,
and we were paid
$25,000 in quarters, which
kind of a dead giveaway
that you're probably not dealing
with a legitimate entity.
But quarters work.
We just walked out like Santa,
with like these big bags
on our shoulder.
I don't know if you've ever
seen $25,000 in quarters,
but bring a truss if you're
going to be carrying that.
Nobody knows what a truss is.
Men's magazines used to
have ads for trusses.
Ask your grandpa.
He probably has one.
But the reason I'm mentioning
this is because this movie,
we had to put in
eight sex scenes.
They told us, kids, we love it.
We just want eight
special scenes.
But because we were punks and
had every badass Hollywood
punk in Hollywood-- including,
weirdly enough, Richard
Belzer, who wasn't a punk
but was in our movie,
and I want to drop
another name because it's
been about five minutes since
I mentioned Nicole Kidman.
And anybody can be legit
if you drop a name.
That's Hollywood.
So we showed this movie
at the Pussy Cat Theater,
now the-- it's no longer
the Pussy Cat Theater,
it's the Ja-- It's
got a new name.
And it's no longer
catering to women.
And back then-- what
is the name now?
I think it's the Jack of Spades
or something really grotesque.
But the point is, there
were Japanese tourists
by the bus load who went for
a big night to this theater
when we made this movie.
We wanted so badly
to be artists,
but we stuck in
these eight scenes.
But we didn't really want
to do a sex movie because we
had integrity, so we made the
most repulsive sex imaginable.
Not repulsive so much as
cold, chilly, distant, odd.
The premise of the movie was
that in the future, which
is coming to pass, there
will be sex negatives and sex
positives.
Those people who can still
have sex perform for those who
can't.
That's the future.
And, perhaps the present.
But again, I don't mean
to brag, but as an artist,
this was such a big
moment of my life.
I was pulling up to the
theater just in time
to see I'd say about 40 Japanese
businessmen running scared
with their hands over their
mouths out of the theater
and into their tour bus because
apparently we had succeeded
in writing some really
anti-sexual sex.
And the point of that is,
we ended up replacing "Pink
Flamingos"-- John Waters,
some of you might have heard
of-- as the midnight movie
Friday nights at the Nuart
Theater.
Am I bragging?
No.
I'm only saying,
ladies and gentlemen,
that if my career
is any indication,
the worst possible
shit can happen to you.
And the worst failures-- I'm
tearing up now on the inside--
can turn into a triumph.
And if you're an artist,
the great thing about being
an artist-- if I
can flatter myself
with that word--
or a novelist, is
that out of the worst moments
of despair and torment
is your greatest material.
Hence the thatch of chest
hair in "con," "can", "cans."
Cannes.
Cannes, right?
"Con" man.
We've got the "con"
man over here.
You really feel
faith in a speaker
when he can't pronounce
Cannes when he's been there.
It's how it is.
It's not everything
it's cracked up to be.
There's about 16 stars and
then 75 blocks of parasites.
I was in the middle.
I was the chest hair
freak with the brok--
I'm so obsessed with that.
It still kills me.
My big day, and I'm
blast-- Nicole Kidman.
Clive Owen.
Either way, I'm not
up to Clive standards.
And that is my
inspirational message.
If you're having a bad day,
if you're having a bad life,
if you're listed on the
internet as having a bad wife,
it doesn't matter.
You can turn it all into triumph
and use that badness and shame
and terror and self loathing
and mortification and agony
to write a book that will
get you an audience at Google
while people are
eating their lunch.
Thank you so much for having me.
I hope this meant
something to someone.
And that's it.
Thank you.
I was told there will be a
question and answer period.
I'm not getting a big question
vibe, but if there are, please
don't be ashamed.
Clearly I have no shame.
I was up here speaking proudly.
The gentleman
asked the question,
how did the lady who took every
known drug who huffed paint,
who ate painkillers,
who took heroin,
who drank, who went
so far as to eat
genetically modified soybeans,
most dangerous of all,
how did that baby turn out?
It turned out perfect.
Thank you for asking.
Because in the end, you
want a happy ending.
Clearly.
Especially in a book like this.
Because a lot of
people say, when
they categorize a writer
or a novel-- everybody gets
put in categories.
I'm generally-- I'm
a feel good guy.
That's where I am.
So that's the ending.
It turned out perfect.
Thank you for asking.
Do you have children?
They good?
It all work?
You know, don't get me started
on how Monsanto caused asthma
by everything they eat
has pesticides in it
now because the anti-pesticides
and the pesticides both--
because that's
Monsanto, covering
both sides of the
street-- are in the food.
And every kid now is
being born with asthma.
Scant help for you,
but it's a tragedy.
All kidding aside,
it's a tragedy.
How are they doing?
They doing the steroid inhaler?
Yeah?
You think it's just the smog?
Yeah.
Good, good.
I have no medical diploma.
So please take your
advice from me.
Are there any other questions?
If not, thank you.
It's really been an honor.
And I hope something
here hit somewhere.
Appreciate it.
Oh, another question.
Or were you waving goodbye?
I couldn't tell.
The idea for "Hemingway
and Gellhorn?"
Actually, the director,
Philip Kaufman,
who-- I don't know if any
of you are film buffs.
He did "The Right Stuff," "Henry
and June," "The Unbearable
Lightness of Being."
He came to me because
Hollywood being Hollywood,
1 out of every 10
projects goes anywhere.
I mean, basically
an idea-- ideas
are like sperm in Hollywood.
Like one out of every five
bazillion spermatozoa make it,
and something results.
So I didn't pitch it.
They came to me with the idea.
I am, as you can
probably tell, not
the best pitcher in the world.
But I try not to
have to go anywhere
where I have to sell
myself because you'd rather
have them call you.
So this was just one
of those lucky breaks
where the director
brought me in.
And originally, the late James
Gandolfini, who was a producer,
was going to play Hemingway,
which would have given it
a whole other, insert joke here.
But great guy, and he,
despite his whole image,
had a very deep other
sort of artist side
to him, which is
pretty wonderful.
And that obviously
didn't work out,
and we switched to Clive Owen.
But happily, to
answer your question,
I did not have to pitch.
Did you ask that
because you have
some ideas you'd
like to-- are you
a screenwriter, potentially?
You've got to get known.
Yeah.
I know.
I got really lucky
because literally, I
went from living essentially
on the street with nothing
to I write this
article, which becomes
a book, which Ben
Stiller picks up.
And then after we got the
money for "Permanent Midnight,"
it disappeared, and he
just said to me, hey,
would you like to
write a movie with me.
And we became friends.
"What Makes Sammy Run," which is
a famous book by Budd Schulberg
about Hollywood, he
asked me to write that.
So literally, I'm
on a private jet,
like Sly Stallone's
private-- I'm
eating Sly Stallone's
left over tuna sandwiches
on a private jet to Saint Bart
after living in the street six
months earlier, and
I got the bends.
So I just got lucky.
So I guess my
advice is get lucky.
But you seem like a very smart
individual, so I would say,
eloquent as you seem to be,
just write what the hell you're
going to write.
Don't ask for approval.
They'll just give you notes that
will destroy your fucking idea.
So just do what you
want to do, and then
after the first 75
people reject you,
the 76th one will take you.
It will be a hit, and then
everybody will imitate you,
and they'll call you derivative.
And that's how it works.
And good luck.
I can say I knew you when.
I feel like a footnote
to film history.
But just finish it.
What the hell?
Just write something good, and
it'll get-- especially now.
With the internet, people
make movies so goddamn cheap,
you can bypass all the
crap that most people
used to have to go through.
So you're obviously in a
place with all the equipment
you need.
And you have an amazing AV guy.
I can tell because I
looked at your monitor,
and you couldn't
see my chest hair.
So that is the sign
of a good AV guy.
Any other questions,
aside from grooming tips?
All right.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.